说话人 1: 哈喽，兄弟们，欢迎来到真实社交，我是 Jackson 本人
说话人 1: 今天给大家带来一期聊天的一个案例讲解
说话人 1: 聊天的案例讲解我们会比搭讪的案例讲解出的要少，因为聊天的案例讲解它的观赏性非常的强，它是能一针见血的看到结果，它的价值也非常的多，因为我会给出一个很具体的一个思路
说话人 1: 当然不是说搭讪讲解不
说话人 1: 重要，反而搭讪讲解更重要，因为那是认识妹子的第一步，而且是面对面的一个沟通，比聊天需要的反应力，需要的思路，更加的逻辑，更加的缜密，所以搭讪的讲解也是非常重要的
说话人 1: 给大家一个点，就是你聊天的时候不要看我的话术，不要看我的惯例，你要理解我的一个逻辑思维，这一点非常的重要
说话人 1: 我给大家介
说话人 1: 介绍一下这个聊天的一个背景
说话人 1: 当时是在一个冬天，就是今年的 1 月份，大家可以看到日期是1月 8 号，是在一个商场里面
说话人 1: 当时我是看到她的背面，大概判断出一个年龄，比我大一点
说话人 1: 她是据我了解，她后面是 30 岁的样子，跟我差不多，比我大一点点
说话人 1: 也是拍开她的肩膀上去检验她的一个颜值，发现还不错
说话人 1: 错，就跟她聊起来，聊到后面感觉还行，没有很土，也没有很下头的价值观，所以我就选择收了她的一个号
说话人 1: 发生了一个小插曲，到了最后收号走的时候，有一个男的突然出现，应该是她的朋友
说话人 1: 我的目标应该是在等她的朋友，就那个男的，看了我一眼，就直接跟他一起走了
说话人 1: 我根据肢体语言，还有女生的神态，女生的感觉，发现那并不是她的男女朋友关系
说话人 1: 甚至于可能连备胎都算不上，只是普通朋友
说话人 1: 当然她有没有男朋友，有没有老公，对我们操作，对我们跟她发生什么，影响并不是很大，主要还是看她是什么情况，我们在应对什么操作
说话人 1: OK，我们看一下聊天记录
说话人 1: 当时是 8 号， 6 点钟， 6 点一十几分，她把我通过了，隔了
说话人 1: 大概 10 分钟内，我就打了一个招呼，我说刚有点唐突哈，我是杰杰
说话人 1: 大家一定要记得，在你搭讪或者说才通过妹子的 10 分钟以内，一定要把消息发出去，一定要试探一个窗口，一定要把那个熟悉度给延续下去
说话人 1: 你不能通过之后就不敢去发消息，很多兄弟他可能是因为脑子里害怕失败，害怕妹子拒绝他，害怕妹子给不好的窗口，他就迟迟不去发消息，这样就
说话人 1: 就导致你们之间的一个熟悉度在往下降，这种是很不好的一个行为，所以你要尽快的把那个消息发出去
说话人 1: 发这句话刚有点唐突哈，这也是我们的一个同理心，代表我们是一个正常人，我们知道什么是唐突的，什么是尴尬的，什么是让人觉得紧张的，代表你是一个正常人
说话人 1: 你要进入跟妹子同一个频道，你们才能正常的沟通下去，你们才能正常的把你的操作给打
说话人 1: 打下去，这个女生她当时是隔了半个小时才回复的我，隔了半个小时才回复我的没事，代表她对这个东西表示很理解
说话人 1: 她的情绪在中间，没有很高，也没有很低，就在中间，比较合格的一个安全线
说话人 1: 具体的一个技术点，这里她是隔了半个小时才回复的我，我当时是在想，因为当时是饭点，这个女生她隔了半个小时才回复我，要么就是她平
说话人 1: 男生聊天，或者说跟男生接触，她都有点装逼，非要把时间拖得很长，代表她没有任何的需求感，这是第一点
说话人 1: 第二点可能是她的日常生活非常的忙，连回消息都可能要排很久才回，可能隔很久才看时间
说话人 1: 但是第二点的可能性比较低，因为当时是饭点，她也没有工作，而且我当时看她的状态也比较闲，问她要去什么，她说要去吃饭
说话人 1: OK，我大概知道是第一种情况
说话人 1: 咱们就要打出第一种情况的一个操作
说话人 1: 因为我当时还在继续跟认识妹子嘛，我也看了这条消息，我后面也忘了回了
说话人 1: 我到了第二天的下午 4 点钟，我就问她这周哪天有空啊
说话人 1: 打算接触你一下
说话人 1: 我给大家说，你们的聊天一定要围绕一个主题，就是把妹子约出来，就是你的目的一定要明确
说话人 1: 我根据上一条消息，我发现她的心情在中间
说话人 1: 没有很高也没有很低，OK，我就做一个邀约，这个邀约当然是个试探，我知道大概率第一条邀约，像这种我只发现了一条消息，没有很有确信感，但也不是很没有确信感，我会去试探一下他的窗口到底是如何
说话人 1: 有什么情况不能试探
说话人 1: 我给大家说，如果他的反应很垃圾，你就不要去试探了，你就要继续聊
说话人 1: 如果他的反应在正常，或者说反应
说话人 1: 很好，还可以，你就要马上邀约，这对于你们来说是效率最高的一张牌
说话人 1: 如果是我的话，我可能会他情绪很好的时候，我再去做深入的吸引，我会再跟他聊，有时候我会聊，有时候我会直接邀约，这个看我当时的一个心情，看我当时想不想跟他，想不想跟他扯淡
说话人 1: 但是对于你们来讲，你最好就是他在中间或者说往上的一个情绪的时候，你就去做一个邀约，把你的意图
说话人 1: 给阐述出来，这是最好的一个试探
说话人 1: 他隔了 20 分钟就给我回复了，他打了一个问号
说话人 1: 我当时在搭讪的时候，其实我的意图是很强烈的，我是完全进入了一个框架，只是说没有聊到性话题，但聊到了一些情感经历
说话人 1: 但是到了聊天上，到了这个时间点，他当时的情绪，还有记忆点已经下降了，所以说他不是很确认你的意图，他就打了一个问号
说话人 1: 这个时候咱们不要怕，我们只需要把意图
说话人 1: 图，继续给他种下去就行了
说话人 1: OK，然后我给他发了，我说约你喝咖啡，看你哪天有时间
说话人 1: 这里我把这个意图给他收了，然后他也回复我一个具体的时间
说话人 1: OK，这里咱们已经确认了，已经约了具体时间了，不需要再去废话，特别是像这种感觉说话很理性，没有任何拖泥带水的那种女生，你就尽量不要去废话，确定好事情
说话人 1: 安排好事情就行了
说话人 1: 我说，周四当天早点再跟她确认
说话人 1: 到了周三的时候，这个女生她还是心里非常有数，她心里还是有你这个人的位置，她还能记得你这个人
说话人 1: 他提前一天跟我说，他说弟弟周四有事，周末再约吧
说话人 1: OK，这种咱们不需要转一个框架，因为他已经很有诚意的提前通知你了，你就不需要把框架拉的很高去责备他
说话人 1: 我说OK，妹妹，那周六喽
说话人 1: 其实这个点我们已经在进入一种调侃，一种性张力的一个状态
说话人 1: 他说我比你大，应该叫弟弟
说话人 1: 我说那可不行，我不是吃亏的主
说话人 1: 很多兄弟不要学这种话术，我可以不发这个消息
说话人 1: 我发这个消息只是把他上面明天有事，周末再约的爽约的那种负
说话人 1: 负能量的事，给它淡化一下，那种不好的情绪，给它淡化一下，把情绪又拉到好的地方，知道吧
说话人 1: 我是想这样一个操作，当然不操作这个也可以，只是说操作了它会更好
说话人 1: 具体不是这两句话把它干住的，你们得知道
说话人 1: 然后我又回他，我说，而且在韩剧里，不管女生大还是小，都是叫我哥哥
说话人 1: 我的意思是，在韩剧里面，只要是那种情侣关系
说话人 1: 不管我是比她大还是比她小，她都得叫哥哥
说话人 1: 我再给她定一个框架，我再给她定一个我们俩之间应该发展的一个关系，必须是男女的一个关系，而不是那种做朋友，那种很安全，不是做那种关系
说话人 1: 我这里到了星期四，她说她周末也有安排了，她说周五可以下午茶
说话人 1: 这里确实是我周五当天
说话人 1: 有事，因为我跟她约的周四，她跟我约的周五，她说周五可以下午茶
说话人 1: 其实这个女生她是很有主导意识，可能她的安全感不是很足，可能以前的关系她都是很强势的那种，她来安排我的时间，喝什么茶
说话人 1: 在这里我当时在想，第一，我周五确实是有事，我当然是可以挤出时间来跟她见面，但是我不想被一个女人牵着鼻子走，让一个女人来安排，让你
说话人 1: 一个女人来引导，所以咱们要把无需求感给表达出来，我不一定非要见你，我是一个男人，什么事只能我来安排
说话人 1: 我说OK，周五我会很忙，因为那个时候快过年了，我说那开年后我们再约吧
说话人 1: 她回了个OK
说话人 1: 大家可以看到，到了过年后，大概是元宵过后吧，我又拍了拍她，准备约她，她给我回了一个问号
说话人 1: 这里咱们废话不多说，又是进行一个调度，大家以
说话人 1: 一定要记得不要扯淡，特别是年纪比较大，时间观念都非常严格的女生，直奔主题就好
说话人 1: 所以我问她，我说你在重庆吗
说话人 1: 她说对，这里我发了语音，语音内容就是邀约，问她啥时候有空，约个咖啡
说话人 1: 她给了我一个具体时间，下个月月初
说话人 1: 我回了一个OK，后面我就没有回了
说话人 1: 为啥没有回
说话人 1: 我给兄弟们一个点，因为我是准备到了月初的时候，我再去给她发消息，所以说我们不会回这条多余的消息，你回个OK，回个什么，女生大概率她是不会在下一条消息回复你，所以说咱们不需要回复她，直接到了那天把消息发出去，邀约就完事了
说话人 1: 很清晰、很简洁、很明了的一个逻辑
说话人 1: 然后到了月初，我给她发了一个表情包，她也知道我是什么意思，她回了一个旋转的表情，我当时感觉不太
说话人 1: 妙，如果说你想正常的女生，你给她发了表情包，她要装作不知道，她会给你打问号
说话人 1: 她如果知道，她会直接说具体的时间
说话人 1: 她发了一个表情包，我当时就觉得，可能要水
说话人 1: 但是我们只能选择无视，因为你不想让这件事情失败，所以说我在往好的方向推，我问她哪天，她也知道我问的是什么
说话人 1: 很多东西，兄弟们，很多东西不需要说的很明白
说话人 1: 我可以问哪天，我可以问哪，我或者说我直接发个哪，我只发一个字，我发个哪，或者说我拍一拍，他就知道你要干什么
说话人 1: 这个东西就叫同频道，这个东西就叫频道，你们在同一个频道，你放个屁，他都知道你在干嘛
说话人 1: 这个是很重要的一个东西，浅沟通很重要的一个东西，你要知道人与人之间沟通的
说话人 1: 人与人之间要沟通的很到位，感觉很到位，不需要他们的不需要发那种很长的聊天，那种小作文，那种花里胡哨的惯例，那些花里胡哨的话术，不需要
说话人 1: 你们在同一个频道，你们是同一种人，你们是很相近的一个价值观，你只需要做一些很简洁的事，对方都知道你在干嘛
说话人 1: 他这里给我发了一条消息，他说我没回重庆
说话人 1: OK，这里我有点生气，当然我
说话人 1: 本人是不生气的，但是我们要给女生一些惩罚性，让她知道什么事是对的，什么事是错的
说话人 1: 因为她水了我两次了，所以咱们必须说一下这个点
说话人 1: 我说你比江渝女生都要水
说话人 1: 我的意思是，本来江渝女生都很水了，就重庆的女生都很水了，她比重庆女生还要水
说话人 1: 为什么要说这句话
说话人 1: 第一点，他确实水了我，这是第一点
说话人 1: 第二点是我在暗示，我身边我接触的女生比较多，让她大概了解一下我的一个情感的一个情况
说话人 1: 她回了一个呵
说话人 1: 大家可以看到这个时间跨度，因为她没回重庆嘛，咱们稍微调侃一下，你比江渝女生都要水，就行了，不需要聊很久
说话人 1: 你要知道，你再跟她聊很久，你也没有结果，她没有回重庆，你怎么样都见不到她，你们再扯淡也没啥用
说话人 1: 所以说我是选择了直接没有回复她
说话人 1: 你们可以看一下这个时间跨度，又隔了一个月，整整一个月，从1月份约到 4 月份，很多兄弟可能几天就扛不住了，可能几天就放弃了，整整从 1 月份约到 4 月份，什么叫坚持
说话人 1: 这就叫坚持
说话人 1: 当然你需要很明智的一个坚持，你不能盲目的坚持
说话人 1: 你如果是一条舔狗，你天天去舔她
说话人 1: 那个东西不叫坚持，那个东西叫骚扰
说话人 1: 基本做人的一个度你得把握好
说话人 1: 学 game 先学会做人，你这个人做好了，你的人品，你的生活圈经营好了，你这个人的 game 就不会差，你做任何事都不会差
说话人 1: 所以你自己内核，你自己的心态，你的 inner game，这方面的一个东西非常的重要，这是支撑你根本的一个框架
说话人 1: 然后
说话人 1: 这里到了4月初的时候，我直接给她取了一个外号，我说水水
说话人 1: 今天还好吗
说话人 1: OK，她这里知道我是在有埋怨，有调侃，她也比较不好意思，又给我发了一个表情包
说话人 1: OK，这个时候她的框架已经往下弱了，她已经弱化了
说话人 1: 什么时候女人的框架开始弱
说话人 1: 是她知道自己做的事，不管是她的框架
说话人 1: 或者是他做了某一件事，他觉得他自己错了
说话人 1: OK，这个时候你就可以疯狂的建立你的框架了
说话人 1: 这里他回复我一个，他说刚健完身
说话人 1: 咱们可以看出这个女生她是比较自律，我不管她练不练的好啊，女生都能去健身，哪怕她是三天打鱼两天晒网，我也觉得比很多男的都要好
说话人 1: 好的多了，所以说可以看出她是一个比较注重生活品质的一个女生
说话人 1: OK，这里我直接回了她一句，我说所以咱们晚上喝个开水庆祝一下
说话人 1: 这里我其实有两个意思，第一肯定是邀约嘛，喝个东西邀约
说话人 1: 第二个意思是因为你才健完身，咱们就去喝个开水去庆祝一下，因为你健身，你就只能喝开水，没有糖分的东西
说话人 1: 她回复了我，她说有啥可庆祝的
说话人 1: 她的关注点在庆祝上面，也是跟上了我的一个话茬子，所以我这里给出了一个惯例，我说庆祝我们三个月没有见
说话人 1: 我这里还在强调我们三个月没见了，这次你千万不能再水我
说话人 1: OK，她这里回复我，她说周末吧，今天太累了，明天还要出差，得回去收拾东西
说话人 1: OK，到了这里我就知道
说话人 1: 这个事情已经稳了，因为他给了我一个很详细的安排与回复，很认真的一个回复
说话人 1: 兄弟们一定要知道什么是女人真正的答应了你的邀约，她会具体说出她的顾虑、她的时间、她的安排、她的行程，是认真的在回答你这个东西，这就是一个真正的邀约，而不是那些很水的女生，那些很鸽的女生
说话人 1: 哦，我们再看吧，到时候再说吧
说话人 1: 那些就是很假的，你们要学会判断这个东西
说话人 1: 我说周末见了，你太忙了
说话人 1: 后面的事情就是当天的一个调度的情况，因为前面的事已经确定好了，他也确实有时间了，给我也很有确信感，因为他给我详细解释了很多，我就知道这一次肯定能见得到
说话人 1: 所以说大家不要再纠结于什么话术，我这个聊天基本上没用什么话术，就完全是调度等待
说话人 1: 调度，等待，就一直重复的这个操作，要有耐心，要坚持，去做一个男人该做的事，引导、调度，还有你的一个无需求感，非常重要的几个方面
说话人 1: 这里我当时是午睡了一下，我说会晚到 20 分钟，午睡了一下，大家如果真的会有迟到，你们第一次见面，你需要去礼貌一点，代表你还是比较在乎这些
说话人 1: 你不能完全表现出不在意这次约会
说话人 1: OK，如果你真的很不在意这次约会，那么你可以表达出你心里的感觉
说话人 1: 但如果你只是假装不在意这次约会，我建议你不要装出来，因为女生她的嗅觉非常的灵敏，她能闻得出来你在装
说话人 1: 如果女生发现你在装，她瞬间就会下头，她马上就会
说话人 1: 女生非常讨厌装逼的男人，因为她
说话人 1: 他们的一致性断裂了，他是很虚伪的人
说话人 1: 一致性断裂的人是很虚伪的人，任何人都不会喜欢，任何人都会讨厌这个人
说话人 1: OK，这是完整的一个聊天记录，给大家总结一下，这个聊天到邀约的一个时间跨度是非常的长，从 1 月份到 4 月份，就整整 4 个月的时间，才把这个女生约出来
说话人 1: 主要靠的是什么
说话人 1: 第一是坚持
说话人 1: 坚持你的意图，坚持你的引导性，坚持你作为男人该做的事
说话人 1: 第二点是掌握好你的分寸，你不要去说那些废话，不要去做那些无谓的操作，不要太有需求感，无所谓一点
说话人 1: 你把这些点做好了，基本上女生她至少不会反感你这个人，你都有机会进入接下来的一个操作，接下来的一个约会，当面的一个操作
说话人 1: 而在约会，你只要保持
说话人 1: 不犯错，你这个人就已经比其他的男人强了
说话人 1: 你要知道，这些女生在她的生活里接触的那些男人，有多么的计科，有多么的屌丝，有多么的装逼
说话人 1: 你只需要做水平线，做到及格线，就已经够了
说话人 1: 你做到及格线，就已经比那些男的
说话人 1: 你要知道现在大多数男的都是那种很low、很、很装逼，你只需要做到水平线，做到及格线，就 OK 了，就已经很棒了
说话人 1: OK，大家仔细体会一下我当时跟妹子聊天的一个心理和状态，一种无所谓的状态，一种引导的感觉
说话人 1: 这是今天的一个聊天案例讲解，下期再见